hallo ihr lieben wir läuten heute
offiziell die weihnachtssaison auf k s
kitchen ein den heutigen lebkuchen
tiramisu an dem rezept seid ihr nicht
ganz unschuldig denn ich frage mich
immer wieder was genau möchte dir für
rezepte sehen was verbindet ihr wird
weihnachten und die top drei antworten
natürlich auch neben den klassikern
ideen ist kommen werden waren erstens
lebkuchen
zweitens irgendwas mit kirschen original
zitat von euch irgendwas location und
drittens klassiker neu interpretiert und
ich habe mir jetzt im tiramisu
vorgenommen und er besitzt umgewandelt
in ein richtig leckeres und
weihnachtliches tiramisu und wir starten
zuallererst mit den kirschen und dafür
zeige ich euch die zutaten dafür
benötigen wir sauerkirschen aus dem glas
außerdem speisestärke und zucker so für
die tier spülung werden wir jetzt den
kirschsaft einmal aufkochen und ein
wenig eindecken lassen allerdings möchte
ich die kirche nicht so matschig haben
deshalb werde ich jetzt mit hilfe eines
siebs einmal separat behandeln einmal
direkt in den topf abtropfen lassen
auch das zweite glas
[Musik]
so die kirchen benötigen nämlich gleich
erst und jetzt gehen wir in den tisch
sagt unsere speisestärke unserem zucker
und rühren dass einmal schön filmchen
frei
[Musik]
so als nächstes werden wir den herrn
einschalten auf höchster stufe und dann
lassen wir es ganz so einmal aufkochen
unter ständigem rühren bis das ganze
richtig schön einlegt
[Musik]
so der kirschsaft kocht und das ganze
ist jetzt minimal ein gedicht ich möchte
das nicht ganz dick haben weil dann auch
der anschnitt schöner ist und jetzt
geben wir als nächstes unsere kirchen
reihen der herd kann ausgeschaltet
werden und was auch wichtig ist bitte
bitte nehmt euren kochlöffel und kein
schnee sonst macht ihr euch die schönen
kirchen kaputt
[Musik]
so unseren leckere kirsch ist auch schon
fertig aber sie muss jetzt erst mal
auskühlen bevor wir weiter machen dafür
nehme ich sie jetzt aus dem topf und
gibt ihnen eine andere schüssel und da
lassen das ganze ungefähr 30 tristem und
40 schön aus können
[Musik]
so ihr lieben während unsere kirschen
jetzt abkühlen ich habe übrigens bei der
jahreszeit tür auf dem balkon gegeben
dann geht es ein bisschen schneller
kümmern wir uns eben um die restlichen
zutaten und ich habe hier einen boden
mit lebkuchen und eine richtig schöne
spekulatius mascarpone creme und dafür
zeige ich euch jetzt die zutaten
wir benötigen nun lebkuchen sauerkirsch
lecter mascarpone schlag sahne creme
fraiche außerdem puderzucker sahne fest
und etwas spekulations gewürz so wir
starten jetzt zuallererst mit unserem
lebkuchen boden und das geniale ist
falls ihr lebkuchen irgendwie auf dem
tisch stehen das macht mir total trocken
sind
dann haben sie für das rezept perfekt
geeignet denn wir führen gleich noch
unser sommer kirschneck dahin zu und
dadurch werden wir definitiv wieder
total saftig das erste was jetzt machen
ist unsere lebkuchen schön auf ein
schneidebrett legen und dann mit dem
messer einmal richtig ordentlich durch
hacken
[Musik]
unser lebkuchen ist jetzt vollständig
fein gehackt und jetzt nehmen wir uns
eine ausreichend große auflaufform und
ich habe jetzt eine rote genommen
nämlich dass so ein weihnachten erinnert
aber ich werde euch die maße auch gerne
nochmal hier ins video oder unten in die
infobox schreiben und jetzt gehen wir
unser lebkuchen einfach da rein und dazu
noch den kirschneck
[Musik]
so wie schon erwähnt kommt jetzt der
sauerteig schlechter drauf und das macht
das ganze eben noch mal richtig schön
saftig
[Musik]
mit einem löffel habe ich das noch mal
richtig schön unter gemeng damit sich
das auch gut verbindet und als nächstes
nimmt euch ganz einfach einen löffel
rücken und drückt das richtig schön an
der boden ist vorbereitet das gebe ich
kurz an die seite und hole meine zutaten
für stück das system aus dem kühlschrank
ich habe sie nämlich in der zwischenzeit
dem kühlschrank gelagert denn kalt
schlägt sich alles besser auf und dann
zeige ich euch jetzt die zubereitung für
die leckere crêpes verwende ich
persönlich jetzt die küchenmaschine
natürlich gilt aber wie immer ihr könnt
auch ein handrührgerät verwenden und die
grillen geht auch super schnell wenn ihr
beachtet dass die zutaten allesamt kalt
sind dann müsst ihr sie einfach nur in
die schüssel geben und dann bei voller
stufe einmal aufschlagen
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt alle zutaten in der
schüssel bis auf mein sohn ist dass ich
nämlich gleich erst langsam ein riesen
und ich werde das so zu machen dass sich
erst die niedrige stufe dem und dann
immer höher geht bis ich das ganz so
richtig schön auch schon ist
[Musik]
schon nach zwei minuten auf vollster
stufe ist unsere creme auch schon fertig
zeigt euch fertig konsistenz also so
fest ist jetzt und jetzt müssen wir
einfach nur noch alle komponenten
verbinden und dann sind wir auch schon
fast fertig so ihr lieben jetzt kommt
der spaßigste teil wir werden jetzt das
tiramisu zusammenstellen dafür habe ich
hier meinen boden die abgekühlten
kirchen und natürlich unsere creme wo
beispiel von der creme einige es hier
schon in einen spritzbeutel gefüllt habe
mit einer lochtiefe vorne dran weil wird
dann gleich schön die tröpfchen auf
topfen genauso wie im echten tiramisu
und jetzt fangen wir an die creme zu
schichten
[Musik]
sobald die creme glatt verstrichen wurde
gehen wir die kirchen komplett drauf und
dann nämlich am besten der schöpfkelle
dann habe ich ein besseres gefühl dafür
[Musik]
und auch die kirchen kommt jetzt die
restliche sahne creme
jetzt mache ich das so dass ich die
hälfte der übrig gebliebenen seine team
glatt drauf streiche und die andere
hälfte die habe ich ja wie gesagt um
einen spritzbeutel gegeben und wird es
dann schön dekorativ auf töpfen
[Musik]
so und fertig gedruckt und zum schluss
kommt nur noch als krönender abschluss
quasi back ak oben drüber dann nehmt
bitte nicht den trinker kaut sondern
wirklich denen der auch zum backen
geeignet ist und das ganze gebe ich
jetzt durch einen sieht und dann ist
wird ihr am iso auch schon fast fertig
[Musik]
unser weihnachts tiramisu ist fertig es
fehlt nur noch ein klitzekleiner
entscheidender schritt und das ist die
kür zeit die müsst ihr unbedingt
beachten
die dauert auch nur zwei stunden oder
ihr könnt es am vortag zubereiten das
klappt auch aber dann kann die creme
noch mal schön durchziehen und wird noch
mal ein bisschen fester
und dann könnt ihr sie wirklich genießen
mit der familie oder zur auch der
weihnachtsfeier das ganze oder
zerbrechen für 16 portionen das ganze
könnt ihr auch halbieren oder verdoppeln
ganz wie ihr möchtet ich wünsche euch
jetzt ganz viel spaß ihm nachmachen
ihr könnt mir gerne noch mal einen
kommentar auf was denn mich wird
interessieren ich habe jetzt in die
creme spekulationsgewinne mit was habt
ihr noch so für anregungen denn das ist
ja wirklich so etwas durch und durch
mich entstanden ist habt ihr noch andere
lieblings gewürze passend zur
weihnachtszeit dann schreibt sie mit
gerne in die kommentare
ansonsten stehen die genauen
mengenangaben unten in der infobox ich
freue mich wie immer über eure fotos mit
dem hashtag s kitchen auf insider die
gucke ich mir mal alle an
ansonsten hinterlasst diesem video gerne
eindeutig nach oben und natürlich ein
kostenloses abo dann sehen wir uns auch
beim nächsten mal auf die keys kitchen
[Musik]